labyrinth which is directed by British
director christopher smith and that's
going to be a TV series isn't it tell me
about your role in that and what we can
expect from labyrinth in labyrinth I am
oh my god I'm the villain in labyrinth
I'm a very mean woman I am it's been
it's been a great great experience we
shot this movie in South Africa
Christopher is a great way director and
we have so much fun marie-cecile as this
woman also very rich very powerful again
she's the head of a big pharmaceutical
company but she wants to be beautiful
and young forever and and she's
convinced that with this the Holy Grail
which is a ring and some challah books
she wants this books and the ring to
become to be powerful and lived 4,000
views so she's like she can do anything
to get this and she can kill and she
does so she's really really very very
she's prepared to everything she's a
very mean woman and it's very cathartic
very liberating somehow I've never done
any bad bad person you know I've never
played any role like this how much fun
was it then getting really bad getting
really villainous for this role there's
so much fun because I'm a very I'm a
very good person I won't hurt anyone so
with his knife going cutting your throat
you know I was like okay you're a
traitor so you deserve to be killed I
was like telling you it's fine I worked
with John Hurt with many great great
actors
so it's been a great experience tell me
about filming in South Africa which is
where you were on location there weren't
you what is it like filming their
amazing this amazing Cape Town is an
amazing city the nature is except it's
really awesome it's something it's an
experience because I also get a chance
to bring my family so we had chance to
visit around and you know it's a you
really feel like a wide life and it's
beautiful the light is amazing did you
get to do many things off set did you
get to visit the country a little bit
yeah yeah we went to kind of a safari so
yeah yeah I got the chance we were
working 15 hours a day was like well
work work work but I I found a couple of
days off so I found time to I mean I got
the chance to experience something
different and the and the ocean
it's really beautiful and did you know
Kate Moss's novel labyrinth before
you're actually offered the role in the
TV series i know i I've heard about that
novo because in Italy also was really
popular but never read it no then I read
it after so it was a completely
surprised because crucifer told me that
it supposed to be French the actress but
then I don't know how I got lucky they
came in Italy to look for an actress for
Marissa cell so I went to the audition
and I was very happy to get the road we
look forward to that thanks so much to
talking chose you thank you
you